[Music]
I love that quiet that emerges is so
sorry
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation long nose and big
theatres you know the photograph the
Earth from space the next 10,000 years
there are things between next week and
10,000 years from now there are things
from the view outside in the street to
view the planet from a great distance
each one of those graded distances in
time in its space has its own uniqueness
its own message its own peculiarities so
the long view whether in space or in
time scales and nobody has done a better
job of finding out what you can do with
the imagery of Earth in this scaling
mode then our speaker tonight
Benjamin grant we're gonna start at his
request with a video from an old friend
which I think you'll enjoy and then Ben
will come up here from this distant
vantage point the earth might not seem
of any particular interest
but for us it's different consider again
that dot that's here that's home that's
us on it everyone you love everyone you
know everyone you ever heard of every
human being who ever was lived out their
lives the aggregate our joy and
suffering thousands of confident
religions ideologies and economic
doctrines every hunter and forager every
hero and coward every creator and
destroyer of civilization every King and
peasant every young couple in love every
mother and father hopeful child inventor
and Explorer every teacher of morals
every corrupt politician every superstar
every Supreme Leader every saint and
sinner in the history of our species
lived there on the mote of dust
suspended in a sunbeam
the earth is a very small stage in a
vast cosmic arena think of the rivers of
blood spilled by all those generals and
emperors so that in glory and triumph
they could become the momentary masters
of a fraction of a dot think of the
endless cruelties visited by the
inhabitants of one corner of this pixel
on the scarcely distinguishable
inhabitants of some other corner have
frequent their misunderstandings how
eager they are to kill one another how
fervent their hatreds
our posturings our imagined
self-importance the delusion that we
have some privileged position in the
universe are challenged by this point of
pale light our planet is a lonely speck
in the great enveloping cosmic dark
in our obscurity in all this vastness
there is no hint that help will come
from elsewhere to save us from ourselves
the earth is the only world known so far
to harbor life there is nowhere else at
least in the near future to which our
species could migrate visit yes
settle not yet
like it or not for the moment the earth
is where we make our stand
it has been said that astronomy is a
humbling and character-building
experience there is perhaps no better
demonstration of the folly of human
conceits than this distant image of our
tiny world to me it underscores our
responsibility to deal more kindly with
one another and to preserve and cherish
the pale blue dot the only home we've
ever known good evening everyone my name
is Benjamin grant and it's an honor to
be here thank you to Carl Sagan for
setting the stage and I thank you to
start for the introduction it truly is
an honor
so tonight I'm excited to share my story
with you all and reflect on earth our
civilization and all of us from a much
bigger perspective now how did this
become my story to share for that let's
go back five years ago to 2013 then I
was a graduate of college I was working
in New York City working at a consulting
firm I couldn't figure out why everyone
would take their lunch go back to their
cubicle and talk to nobody else that was
weird to me and I wanted to change that
so it was my instinct at the time to
start a space Club yeah space Club it
was as bizarre then as it might seem now
but I did it and here's why I did it
at that time in 2013 there were some
particularly enticing news stories
SpaceX was launching and landing their
grasshopper Rockets I had never seen
anything like this before it was like
something out of science fiction
over the skies of Chelyabinsk Russia a
meteorite entered the sky and released
33 times more energy than one of the
atomic bombs dropped on Japan during
or to you'll see it there and the
Voyager 1 spacecraft the same one that
took the picture of the pale blue dot
that we heard about in the introduction
crossed the heliopause meaning that it
left our galaxy and entered into
interstellar space that was very
profound for me to hear so I was
learning about these stories and sharing
them on a bi-weekly basis at space Club
soon enough about a quarter of the firm
I was at was coming to space Club so it
was going very well and I had put myself
out there as the space guy right it was
a little weird but I was the space guy
and one day I got an email from a friend
at work she said I know you love outer
space I just saw this film I think you
should check it out and I want to share
a few minutes of that movie with you now
[Music]
Oh golly I remember going through launch
which is an overwhelming experience
[Music]
[Music]
the engines cut off I felt myself
floating out of the seat I floated over
to the window looked out and we were
coming up over the coast of Africa and
that's when it hit me I'm in space I'm
you know I just got incredibly excited
because it's something I had dreamed
about since I was six years old I think
you start out with this idea of what
it's gonna be like and then when you do
finally look at the earth for the first
time you're overwhelmed by how much more
beautiful it really is when you see it
for real it's just like it's this
dynamic alive place that you see glowing
all the time
it was truly incredible to be up there
doing what I always wanted to do my
whole life and then to kind of glance
back at our planet and see that view was
just tremendous I can only describe what
I've seen you know looking down at the
earth and you see that that line that
separates day tonight slowly moving
across the planet thunder storms on the
horizon casting these long shadows as
the Sun sets and then watching the earth
come alive and you see the lights from
the cities and the towns the events you
see from space like flying over
thunderstorms looking at them from the
top or spectacular like a firework show
we're going on and you're looking at it
from the very top you know shooting
stars going below us or or you know
dancing curtains of Aurora's it's just
very hard to describe all the you know
the colors the beauty that the motion
[Music]
I'm glad that works you guys could see
what I saw in 2013 that was the film
overview it was 19 minutes long and I
was glued to my screen for the entirety
of it and it would forever change my
life before I tell you why and how I
want to give a little historical context
to explain how this came to be how we
have humans and cameras in outer space
giving us this perspective so for that
story we have to go back to 1957 on
October 4th 1957 the Soviet Union
launched Sputnik an emptied out
intercontinental ballistic missile that
created the world's first artificial
satellite now this caused everyone in
the United States a year later to freak
out and form the National Aeronautics
and Space Administration that we all
know now as NASA because we did not want
to be behind within three years both the
Soviets and the Americans had their
first man in space
the Soviets launched Yuri Gagarin on
April 12th beating the United States by
just a few weeks when Alan Shepard went
on may 5th the next year President
Kennedy took the space race to a whole
new level when he gave the United States
a new target a new destination in a
famous speech that he would deliver on
September 12th at Rice University in
Houston Texas when he famously declared
this
you
so with that speech we were gonna go to
the moon and we were gonna go to the
moon by the end of the decade however it
wouldn't take that long for someone to
have a profound realization that we
needed this perspective and that would
occur right here in San Francisco in
North Beach on the third storey of an
apartment building when a 27 year old by
the name of Stuart brand from his
elevated position thought he could see
the skyline curving on itself and wrote
down in his journal that you can see on
the left why haven't we seen a
photograph of the entire earth yet he'd
been watching Buckminster Fuller
lectures where he was thinking the
belief that the earth is flat is the
source of all of our misbehavior so we
started this campaign where he created
these buttons that you see on the right
that he would send to senators and
congressmen and every single person at
NASA urging them to give us this
perspective so Thank You Stuart
and because of this campaign the
following year the 80s 3 geostationary
weather satellite created this photo the
first full-frame color photo of our
entire planet this photo would then
appear on the cover of the first Whole
Earth Catalog in fall of the following
year oh yeah I might break the record
for most applause tonight let's go but
something profound would happen in 1968
the Apollo missions were still well
underway and Apollo 8 was leaving from
Cape Canaveral Florida to be the first
mission in which humans would leave
low-earth orbit the first mission in
which people would travel with a
destination in mind they were going to
the moon they weren't going to land on
the moon but they were gonna scout out
future locations where we could land and
on Christmas Eve 1968 something magical
happened the astronauts had made it to
the moon they were on their fourth orbit
around and astronaut Bill Anders looked
out the window and he saw something
incredible he frantically asked his
crewmates where their camera was he
grabbed the Hasselblad he pointed it
towards the window he pressed the
shutter and took this picture Earthrise
now this is one of the most well known
widely distributed photographs of all
time and many historians suggest that
this picture this moment sparked the
modern environmental movement as we know
it now that's a pretty big claim but
what is there evidence suggests that
this actually happened first and
foremost the Environmental Protection
Agency was founded the following year
which is an organization until this
administration that was intended to do
just that to protect the environment
which led to many pieces of fundamental
legislation such as the Clean Air Act
the Clean Water Act DDT which was a
pesticide being used on crops was banned
it was killing so many birds and the
Endangered Species Act was passed the
following year Earth Day was created if
you look at the first slogan of Earth
Day it was a day for
looking beyond tomorrow that's long-term
thinking they were looking for a future
worth living and this all came from that
one photograph organizations that are
now some of the leaders in the
environmental movement were founded that
next year with the NRDC or Greenpeace or
one of my favorite examples Doctors
Without Borders
one of my heroes Neil deGrasse Tyson
likes to remark on that name Doctors
Without Borders and says where do you
even get that phrase from no one's
thought of that phrase before that
picture was taken so I believe that
those historians are correct that this
picture in this moment did indeed spark
the environmental movement that is so
necessary in our history moving forward
to 1972 Apollo 17 which would be the
last of the Apollo missions the last
time we would go to the moon the
astronauts captured this photo that you
may recognize the Blue Marble as it's
known this is the last time that we were
able able to capture a photo like this
in the years following Apollo 17 it was
very clear that the Russians weren't
going to go to the moon that the space
race was pretty much over and NASA's
budget decreased significantly as a
result of that so it wouldn't be until
the year 2015 that we had our next Blue
Marble when this picture captured by the
discover satellite from a million miles
away was created just a couple years ago
so that is basically the history of
seeing the earth like that in recent
years space travel for astronauts has
been kind of contained to the shuttle
missions that went to and from Earth to
the International Space Station this is
the shuttle scene over the Bahamas or
the International Space Station which
was operational from the year 2000 to
present seen here so that is how we got
here right and now we've had the
opportunity to look back at all of these
astronauts like the ones we heard in the
video to see and understand what they
were feeling in a study that was
released in 2016 by the University of
Pennsylvania psychology department
examined all of the testimonies from
astronauts to see what they were feeling
and their analysis uncovered three
common feeling
first there was a greater appreciation
for Earth's beauty the astronauts had an
increased sense of connection to all
other living beings on the planet and an
unexpected often overwhelming sense of
emotion this feeling this profound
awakening is commonly called the
overview effect where the movie gets its
name from and where this talk gets its
name from even the first two astronauts
who have this experience Yuri Gagarin
and Alan Shepard came back saying these
things Gagarin was saying how beautiful
the planet was how we needed to protect
and preserve it we can't destroy it he
saw that it was not infinite Alan
Shepard said the same thing not infinite
it's fragile it's vulnerable right this
is an awakening from the very first
moments that we were able to see this
and for me it comes down to this this is
the psychology underlying all of this
awakening all this profound
understanding it's all this is what
we're gonna here to talk about tonight
Oh what is oo-oo-oo occurs when you are
exposed to something perceptually vast
like the entire planet seeing something
immense in size number scope complexity
but what happens when you experience awe
your brain needs to develop new mental
models to understand this new world
you've been exposed to a new frame of
reference right it's basically coping
with what it's seen so over the course
of human history there have been 561
astronauts who have seen the world like
this now I found this figure you may
dispute it but it's approximated that
there have been roughly a hundred and
eight billion people ever so that means
one out of every two hundred million
people have seen the Earth from outer
space and to end this section I just
want to leave you with one question what
if that number were bigger so that comes
back to me 2013 I'm still a consultant
I'm still working at this firm in New
York City still doing Space Club on a
bi-weekly basis and I'm walking around
New York City looking at my phone using
Google Maps like we all do
and I think this is a space story this
is only possible because of GPS I kind
of know what GPS is I'm going to explain
how satellites work I had just seen the
movie overview and it was very much on
my mind I'm obsessed with this idea of
the overview effect so I'm preparing
this talk on satellites I figure I'll
pull in some imagery as well from Apple
maps I just got this new computer these
images look cool so I open Apple maps
and as someone who's obsessed with the
overview effect I typed the word earth
into the search bar yeah earth thinking
it would zoom out and show me the blue
marble like I just showed a few slides
ago so I type in earth I press ENTER
thinking it will zoom out but instead it
zoomed in and this is what I saw this is
Earth Texas
[Applause]
earth Texas is a small town in northeast
Texas with 1048 people I had never heard
of it before
but this is what I saw these perfect
circles these PAC men these pie charts
whatever images conjures for you I
thought it was one of the most
awe-inspiring beautiful things I'd ever
seen
I took my computer I went back to my
apartment and I showed my roommates and
I said what the hell is this what am I
seeing here why is this the way it looks
what what is going on eventually we
found out these circles are pivot
irrigation fields which occur when you
have a line of sprinklers with a central
motor and they go in a perfect circle to
irrigate the crops evenly but that
afternoon this picture set me and my
friends off on this adventure to figure
out what are the places in moments and
landscapes that are these powerful
stories that we can show so I want to
share first a few examples of some of
those places I had a friend there who
was from Europe and he said you should
check out the Port of Rotterdam it's one
of the larger shipping facilities in the
world and this is what we found this
systematic organization of shipping
containers on a massive scale unexpected
beauty I had a friend who had just gone
on vacation in Arizona he said there's
an airplane graveyard there you should
check out this boneyard contains 4,400
retired military aircraft that are kept
in the desert so they do not corrode as
quickly my one friend was working in
energy and he said you should check out
a solar concentrator I had never heard
of a solar concentrator before but this
is one that we found in Seville Spain
and lastly my best friend's girlfriend
was working for an NGO at the time and
she said you should check out the Dadaab
refugee camp in Kenya in this image I
think if there is any image of all of
the ones that I found in the beginning
that helped me realize the potential of
this project the potential of one of
these images to tell a powerful story
this is one it's a beautiful image the
red colour of the Kenyan soil the
beautiful organization and grid on the
Left that we're used to in our cities
catches your attention but when you
learn and you read the caption here that
you're seeing 260,000 displaced Somali
refugees you have a new understanding of
what's going on there so that image and
the other ones I showed kind of set me
off on this adventure to find these
places a few weeks later I created daily
overview the name right there while
coming from the overview effect thinking
about how can I inspire this on a
regular basis I would post one of these
pictures every day and that was the
mission that's how I set off doing it so
a lot has happened over the last five
years and to think about tonight how I
wanted to explain what's happened I was
inspired by a talk that Stewart gave at
Ted in 2004 when he said for many years
I've been trying to figure out how to
hack civilization so that we can get
long-term thinking to be automatic and
common instead of difficult and rare so
at daily overview for five years I've
been trying to figure out how to hack
civilization to inspire the overview
effect on a regular basis now what are
the hacks that I have used to do so the
first one was to figure out how to get
these images of the earth from outer
space if we go back to that first one of
earth Texas that was on Apple Maps and I
did a little bit of digging when this
started all happening to figure out who
owns this is it Google is it apple is it
somebody else and I went into the
information page and buried deep in the
copyrights it said satellite imagery
data copyright digital globe I had never
heard of digital globe before but I did
a quick google search found someone to
call called them up and said I'm an
artist in New York and I'd love to use
your imagery to create new perspectives
for people and they were like what the
hell are you talking about
I showed them some more stuff they did a
background check on me and eventually we
formed a partnership agreement where I
have access to the digital globe
constellation of five satellites now
each of these satellites is about the
size of an ambulance they are equipped
with cameras so powerful that if you
could put one of these satellites on the
Hollywood sign in Los Angeles you could
take a picture of a beach ball on the
Golden Gate Bridge in full resolution
yeah it's crazy and it enables you to
take pictures like this now take a
second to get your bearings but you are
here this is from 900 miles away above
the Pacific Ocean of San Francisco if we
zoom out you can see the entirety of the
Bay Area in one photograph having access
to their imagery also means I have
access to their full archive and library
which means you can tell stories about
changes in time if you have one of these
images you have a moment in time if you
have two overviews you have a change in
time so here are a few examples these
are the tulip fields and lycée
Netherlands which bloom in April of
every year so if you take this first
photograph in March and you compare it
to one captured one month later
you're able to watch the flowers bloom
in this magnificent cascade of color on
a less positive note this is a patch of
desert in Morocco Jordan captured in
2011 the same year that the crisis and
civil war in Syria started if you
compare this land to the same land
captured just this past year in 2017
you're able to see the construction of
the Zaatari refugee camp this is now
home to 83,000 displaced refugees so
these are very powerful stories that
were able to capture and tell the second
hack now that we've got the images how
do you make them look really good what's
the point in doing this if no one's
gonna see them how can we get people's
attention so what you see on Google
Earth is often limited to the resolution
of whatever device you're using to look
at it be it a phone or computer so
you're limited to 1500 2000 pixels what
you see on daily overview in our book on
our website is us taking the time to
extract all of the high resolution in
fro from the satellite stitch it
together over a number of tiles what
you're looking at here is Barcelona so
you can see Google Earth on the left us
on the right and this enables us to do
it on a larger scale as well we can keep
building out the tiles to continue to
give you that high resolution and we're
not just going on the satellites and
looking for one image and saying wow
that's cool there's a lot of thought
that goes into the composition of each
image so when I started the project I
just graduated from college and my
parents had given me a DSLR camera as a
graduation present and I would go for
these long walks on the weekend out in
New York City and the imagery that
appealed to me the most the sites that
appealed to me most were these
architectural landscapes just symmetry
and lines and looking up and looking for
something vast so those were the photos
that were taking I was taking I was also
doing a lot of painting at the time I
don't think any of my paintings are
particularly remarkable but in the
process of doing them I learned about
ideas of composition and color and
putting something together so when I
look at an overview now and what I'm
about to show you I think about abstract
expressionist painters when I do it my
favorite paint
the people who inspire on me when I go
to SFMOMA
so a couple examples when you look at a
cattle feedlot as seen here on left in
Texas it might look a lot like a piet
mondrian grid or ipanema beach in Rio de
Janeiro Brazil resembles a Barnett
Newman strip painting this image of
deforestation in Bolivia matches the
color blocking scheme of an Ellsworth
Kelly and last but not least Lake Mead
in the United States looks a lot like a
Clifford still painting now Clifford
still was a painter who was trying to
depict the American West in an abstract
expressionist form and I wish I could
bring him back to life and show him that
and say you were doing a good job so
yeah the third hack on the cover of the
whole earth analog Whole Earth Catalog
it says access to tools and I think this
project started at a time when I had
access to a few tools that made it
possible to efficiently find new images
and to distribute them to a massive
audience so what are those tools
the first one is Wikipedia we all have
access to Wikipedia it's free it's a
nonprofit and for finding a new place
this was the primary source for doing it
so say we're looking at the solar
concentrator that I showed you before
how would you find one of these places
in this vast world the idea is a solar
thermal station so you go on Wikipedia
there are lists of these places and not
only are there lists that are sorted by
the largest ones in the world there are
coordinates for every single place on
there so you take those coordinates you
put it into the mapping program and you
might find something like this which is
Ivanpah solar panel facility in the
Mojave Desert so now you've got an image
right what do you do with an image I
understood at the beginning that we
wanted to create a digestible and
consistent content stream for daily
overview there is so much going on on a
news feed on social media that we're all
inundated all the time with this stream
of images and information so how can we
make it simple a single post would be
the name of what it was where it was
located the geo coordinates of you
to check it out yourself and then two or
three maybe even a little more sentences
to describe what you're seeing facts and
information entirely objective so that
you could understand what you were
seeing in the frame and learn a bit more
about it
now we've got a post where does it go
how do we get it out there in the world
Instagram Instagram had I think a
hundred million active users when this
project started in 2013 right now it's
estimated that they have 900 to 950
million active users that has a large
large audience to potentially share
these images with and why was it so good
for daily overview first and foremost we
all have massive computers with large
screens in our pockets right now so if
you're an artist doing photography
that's a good thing right you want
people to be able to see and enjoy these
things so we've all got these massive
screens Instagram is visual first so you
would lead with the information I mean
leave with the image get people's
attention and then follow it up with the
information so they could understand
what they were seeing we also have
unprecedented global connectivity now an
example we post an image of the Sydney
Opera House I'm able to go to the geotag
of the Sydney Opera House and see every
single image that's ever been taken
there and posted from someone at the
Sydney Opera House you can then connect
with those people on an individual basis
and say we love your image you should
check it out from above that is
incredibly powerful technology that was
not around 10 or 15 years ago and has
made this whole project possible to get
this new perspective out to people who
may not receive it otherwise and the
last hack very simple tell a very good
story the second week of doing daily
overview I sat on my couch and I wrote a
mission statement that is such a
consultant thing to do but I I was a
consultant at the time and I figured I
needed to define very clearly why I was
doing this and why it was important and
it came down to two things the overview
effect it's what inspired me to start
doing this and this focus on the places
when humans were impacting the planet it
was very simple it was so simple that
when people found the project the story
was already written for them within two
months of starting this
fast company wrote this article and it
wasn't just there on their homepage it
was their number one story for an entire
week I'm freaking out in my office this
is crazy nothing like this has ever
happened to me before and from Fast
Company it went to the most popular
architecture website on the planet one
of the most popular urban planning
websites on the planet
British Airways called me and asked to
do an interview with me that was
incredibly surreal someone in Portugal
wrote a story about it and the largest
museum in Munich Germany said we want to
do an exhibition with your images yeah I
think this is telling though because I
came to the project with this mindset
that it was an environmental story and
it would make sense to do a feature with
Audubon magazine on encroachment in the
Arctic what I could have never imagined
is all the different directions that it
went say doing an entire story about
mining for foreign policy or working
with Four Seasons and other travel
organisations to show their destinations
from above in a new way
the images are so powerful and so large
that it's led to a number of exhibitions
all around the world like the one in
Munich this is one we did just this past
summer in Sweden getting the images out
into a public square rather than behind
closed doors of a gallery we want them
to be accessible and powerful so printed
large and in the public getting the
images into mainstream culture these are
a series of prints that we sell through
C B to C B to C I can't say that C B to
stores so it's kind of mainstream art
but again we still think every
opportunity that these images are seen
is an opportunity to get this
perspective in front of more people and
lastly the book which you may have seen
when you walked in here the book was an
opportunity to crystallize our thinking
and say what does human impact look like
right of course we're going to inspire
the overview effect with these images
but we have the opportunity now to show
what our civilisation is doing and what
it looks like the talk tonight is called
earth and civilization in the macroscope
and the book better than anywhere else
breaks down earth and civilization into
these buckets where we harvest
is all food in agriculture where we
extract is all mining where we power is
all energy so on and so forth so tonight
I want to walk through some of my
favorite images that tell this story
that show you what is going on right now
and what it looks like in an entirely
new perspective
so to start harvest I showed this image
before but I think it's worth showing
again this is deforestation in Bolivia
what you see on the left is the
rainforest that has been cut down and
cleared to raise animals and to do
mechanized agriculture so when I see
this image I'm not just thinking about
the food but the earth that is
sacrificed to get our food it's a very
powerful moment there in the center you
can see that single cut right perhaps a
sign of what's to come or perhaps an
opportunity to save it I think it's very
easy to sit in a place like San
Francisco and say save the rainforest
save the rainforest but when you see an
image like this I think you contemplate
that there are people on the ground on
the left side of the screen who have
families to feed who are trying to make
money and there is a country of Bolivia
who needs food right so you can really
think about this for a long time what is
happening how do we preserve the
rainforest and also make sure that
people are getting the things they need
to live the lives they want these are
canola flowers in lieu of pink County
China yes it is actually that color
thinking about these beautiful
landscapes and also the byproducts of
the oils that are created from doing it
palm oil is another one that is
particularly detrimental to the
environment
another image also from China this shows
aquaculture so these are nets and cages
used to grow the fish that is being used
and consumed on a massive scale where we
extract so all of the things that we
have have to come from somewhere right
if you have a dishwasher or a
refrigerator that is made of stainless
steel it most likely came from an iron
ore mine like this one
in the Pilbara region of Australia 98%
of the world's iron ore is used to make
seamless seal so you can see this
beautiful and scary scar that creates
things we use on an everyday basis or
diamonds perhaps some of you are married
out there or engaged it probably came
from a mind like this in Botswana this
is the largest diamond mine in the world
or lithium we all have lithium ion
batteries this is the world's largest
lithium mine in Bolivia an oil oil has
to be extracted from the ground it's old
shells this is oil extraction on land at
the Dury field in Indonesia we also get
it from the above with platforms of
above water this is the manifold field
in Saudi Arabia one of the largest in
the world and that oil is then used for
energy where we power some of that oil
might go to this refinery in Ulsan South
Korea this is the third largest in the
world
and has a capacity of 1.2 million
barrels of oil every single day looking
at other forms of energy we have
hydroelectric here this is one of the
world's largest dams in China and also
renewable sources of energy like wind
this is the middle Gruden wind farm off
the coast of Copenhagen Denmark where we
live we can learn a lot about the places
we live when we look at them from the
overview perspective there's a
particularly interesting example here
this is the Bay Area in the left you see
East Palo Alto on the right you see Palo
Alto when you look at areas and you look
at the amount of vegetation and green
space that they have you can gauge their
wealth this is a particularly
interesting example where you can see
them both in one frame but then when you
compare images like this one of the
slums of Delhi India where Green is not
detectable whatsoever to the affluent
suburbs of Copenhagen Denmark where
everyone has their own private growing
patch in their own green space and their
own huge front yard you have a new
understanding of the places that we live
where we move so we have these amazing
cities and then we create this
infrastructure to move under through
over them a particularly beautiful
example here in the Bay Area is the
Golden Gate Bridge which I will show in
every presentation ever for the end of
time or the Kansai Airport which is
constructed as an island in water it
looks like it's floating there like a
spaceship millions and millions of
dollars into these infrastructure travel
projects or these beautiful massive oil
tankers and shipping container ships
waiting outside the entry to the port of
Singapore one of the largest facilities
of its kind in the world where we design
so we have these cities and we're
thinking about how can we create
something that's efficient and flexible
and also the buildings that we've built
to make them architecturally sound we've
been doing this for a while
these are the pyramids in Giza on some
of the early examples of design on a
massive form into the modern cities of
Europe like this one of Paris where you
can see the diagonal avenues radiating
from the Arc de Triomphe at the upper
left or the canals of Amsterdam which
was a particularly thoughtful and
beautiful City when seen from above and
then there's art just on a massive scale
for beauty sake this this is a guitar
forest with a particularly beautiful
story it was built by a father and his
children to honor his wife and their
mother who passed and she always loved
guitars and she never had one and they
built this in her honor we also like to
have fun right it's not all waste and
mining and we enjoy the world and we
enjoy our time in it so we build spaces
to enjoy the world this is Central Park
in the midst of our city in New York we
also do it in natural environments too
this is Aspen Snowmass you can see the
ski trails carved out into the side of
the mountain and also on the natural
environment of coral reef this is Bora
Bora and you can see the bungalows that
hotels and resorts have built out into
the perfect blue waters
all of the buckets that I've talked
through already they don't really just
end there
they're often byproducts or things that
come of these systems so where do we
waste right you saw those massive ships
when they are decommissioned they are
often sent to a place like this in
Bangladesh this is a ship breaking yard
where people working in horrible
conditions use explosions and old tools
to scrap the ships for parts all of the
cities that we live in have a lot of
people who are creating a lot of trash
this is a massive landfill in South
Korea part of which is filled to
capacity the other part is soon to be
filled to capacity but we have to think
about this one statistic that says the
wealthy you are the more trash you
generate that is very much seen in these
massive landfills in these major cities
and lastly the mining efforts that we
have all around the world if they are
not handled correctly and if they're not
done thoughtfully they can result in
horrible disasters so in 2015 there was
an iron ore mine in Brazil that had a
dam containing waste which broke this is
the town of bento Rodrigues which was
right next to the mine and when that dam
broke millions of cubic leaders of
wastewater was released wiping out the
entire village killing 18 people and
this waste flooded all the way into the
sea through the Rio Doce River killing
unknowable amounts of plant and animal
life along the way the last chapter
where we are not there are still places
believe it or not where humans have not
yet impacted the landscape and when I
put together this chapter it gave me
some time to think about this right when
you look at this Red Lake in Tanzania or
the perrito Moreno glacier in Argentina
and Patagonia or this massive desert of
sand dudes called The Empty Quarter in
Saudi Arabia you're seeing landscapes
which formed over thousands of years
tens of thousands of years hundreds of
thousand millions of years deep time
right and when you compare that amount
of time to the development scene in
previous eight chapters things that
we've built in the past 5 10 20 years
you not only see how much we're doing to
the planet you see how quickly we are
doing to it so this chapter serves as a
comparison to show you that the earth
has been around a lot longer than we
have and it will be around a lot longer
after we're gone
so that is the book and I'm thrilled to
announce that our current project is
turning this book into a children's book
so that it can be more digestible and
understood by the next generation of
students and lifelong learners who will
inherit all of our climate problems so I
want to end with something I mentioned
before and I didn't tell you the full
story before I was leaving something out
as I said Oh happens when you are
exposed to something perceptually vast I
just exposed you guys to a lot of
perceptually vast things and hopefully
your brain had to develop new mental
models to understand what it was you
were seeing just like the astronauts of
Apollo 8 had to do and everyone who saw
this photograph of Earth rise had to do
when we saw the earth like this for the
first time but here's the part I left
out here's what I'm really excited about
there have been studies in recent years
that have examined what happens to
people when they experience awe on a
regular basis studies in the Bay Area
out of Berkeley out of Stanford and
here's what they found when you
experience on a regular basis it leads
to an increase in pro-social behaviors
right you start thinking about ways you
can help the collective your
decision-making changes and becomes more
ethical when you're exposed to on a
regular basis it makes you more present
and it makes you feel like you have more
time available to you
it's a very powerful tool if you're
doing long now thinking when you feel
like you have more time available to you
you're more generous with your time and
you're more likely to volunteer and
lastly when people experience aw
they report this small self they are no
longer the center of the universe they
recognize that they are tiny and that
feeling of tightness means that they
want to work towards the collective it
increases their willingness and their
desire to collaborate so everything that
I've been doing for the last five years
and everything that I intend to do going
forward in the future will aim to
inspire awe because I believe if I can
inspire awe and we can all seek out awe
we will do what's right and what's
necessary to create a better future for
our one and only home thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah uh looks like Stoney Leibrandt
says do you have any interest in ever
going to space personally I do
okay say more I don't need to be on the
first flight but if the risk is the same
as the flight I'm gonna take
cross-country mm-hmm I'm there and you
want to be in low-earth orbit and see
the kind of stuff you've been seen you
want to get way the hell out there
what's your preference it depends on how
long it's gonna take to get there I
think I need to go at some point at this
at this rate I've dedicated my life to
this and I want to experience it
firsthand I know the images that I'm
creating don't do it justice to what the
astronauts are experiencing mm-hmm so
I'll go wherever they send me it occurs
to me that you know imagery not unlike
this is being made of a place where we
are not which is like the surface of
Mars yeah do you ever have a temptation
to sort of blend in some Mars and see
what people make of it I've showed it a
few times heavy cloud should be shown
more often I think having that new
frontier having a next place to go to is
essential I think it will happen
probably in the next five or six years
probably led by the efforts at SpaceX so
it's great I think if we continue to
look outwards rather than in words that
will serve us all very well do
astronomers engage is what you're doing
and there was Carl Sagan going on about
you know astronomers get their character
built by and what they're doing yeah is
this of interest to astronomers or is
that
a boring planet as far as they're
concerned well they definitely do like
to look outwards more than in words um
but I think the images do have universal
appeal I mean you can critique my
artistic composition as much as you want
but the world is vast and beautiful and
endless and everyone loves looking out
their airplane window and everyone looks
loves looking at the world and seeing it
in a new way so I would hope that
everyone could enjoy the images on some
level it certainly makes me realize not
everybody likes looking at the airplane
ones I thought it's not like yea they
pull the shade down and watch a movie or
whatever but also partly looking out the
airplane window one is kind of scuzzy
two is kind of small and you bang your
head against it and elect and if you're
in there I'll see you know you're
disturbing whoever you're leaning over
to the kids of you how about
glass-bottom airplanes sign me up
I'm not there if anyone out there can do
that I have business cards afterwards
that would be it's gonna be directly
doable I mean you know that is he sings
under the ocean you can see straight
through them why not it's probably some
FAA regulation where they want us to
watch the TVs and how much the coming of
drones affected which is happening sort
of in this period of time you'd be doing
this and people are getting these flying
cameras and outlet drones in getting
used to that image and they're driving
these cameras around is that
intersecting let you do it all
definitely I have a couple drones myself
and definitely go and enjoy that
perspective and you can capture things
from drones which you can't capture from
satellite some of your own drone images
and your segment on the feed yeah every
once in a while I think yeah as I said
it's complimentary I think there are
things which you can capture from drone
that you can't capture even from a
helicopter and then going higher up
there are things that we can capture
from satellite which photograph or
photographers from helicopters can't
capture I I often get people say have
you heard of Edward Burtynsky or Yann
Arthus Bertrand all these incredible
people who
this long before I was and I say yes
absolutely I've been incredibly inspired
by the work that they've done and
continue to do but I think they're
complementary whereas Edward Burtynsky
can get the details of a mine and the
people working in the mine I have the
ability to show that entire mind which
he wouldn't be able to do so I like to
think of them as complementary processes
and have the utmost respect for the work
that they've done
have you ever intersected with ed
Burtynsky I have not okay look he's done
actually a very interesting Salt talk
some years ago and will be coming back
when the Anthropocene projects that he's
been working on is come to maturity
excellent where do you live I live in
NOPA and we're north of the Panhandle
it's what all the kids are saying these
days interesting a couple questions
about Kevin Kelly's a photographer
himself mostly at low altitude his axes
her photograph you wish you could take I
wish it was not so cloudy in Hawaii
right now so I could get some of the
volcanoes that are up there but that's
that's what happens sometimes we we can
have an idea of what we want to show and
we can go and look and it can either be
disappointing or it's cloudy or there's
not imagery it happens kind of more
often than I would like
have you gotten many well you had this
basically flood effect
have you gotten other natural phenomena
of weather and yeah we had some
incredibly it was almost painful to look
at imagery from the Santa Rosa fire last
year you could see the before and after
of a neighborhood that was there and
then no longer there there have been
floods hurricane Harvey we had some
imagery from Houston which was
incredibly difficult again to look at
there was the crisis in Myanmar I
believe it was with the possible
genocide and you can see the villages
that were destroyed um so this
perspective generally does lend itself
to telling those stories
incredible way we definitely want to mix
up the content on our website so it's
not just depression and disaster every
single day but it is important that we
show it and we definitely want to make
it a priority to do so well a question
from Liz bowler sort of speaks to that
what if you wanted to take or show an
image of but have been conflicted
whether you should um do you have these
kind of arguments with yourself of well
is this amazing image but I don't know
if I should put it out there
I think the conflict is often in how I
present it I try to do everything in my
power
mm-hmm excuse me I try to do everything
in my power to be as objective as
possible with the information that
corresponds to the image so still write
the copy that goes with the images sorry
what do you always write the copy that
goes from the image I write it and then
I have people check it to make sure that
my environmental liberal bias E is not
too much injected into it because we
want this to appeal to everyone if we
can get this post in front of someone
who has conservative or not typically
kind of environmentally favorable views
and they say wow it's so beautiful and
they look at an oil refinery for 30
seconds that they otherwise would ignore
that's successful
we don't necessarily just want to preach
to the choir all the time we want to get
this out there to as many people as
possible are there places military
places or whatever that imagery just
simply not available area 51 has blurred
out
[Music]
seriously oh come on the aliens must
have blurted out there are there are war
zones we don't have access to I think
they're using that imagery for other
purposes obviously and then sometimes
you can see that people have selectively
blurred out like a port or a company or
they probably don't want someone
monitoring it so we try to stay away
from those areas and stay out of trouble
and make sure this project keeps going
and we don't expose the
extra-terrestrial life that's at area 51
but there are increasingly tell me how
many entities are making satellite
imagery at this point yeah I think it's
upwards of maybe 70 or 80 different
companies right now we work with four or
five so we have access to their archives
but more and more are coming online
every day and those companies are
launching more and more satellites so I
think we're excited about that I think
that means the overview effect will
become more prominent and more of a
thing in the future we also think that
is going to become more of a thing with
space tourism there's kind of this new
space race of billionaires with Virgin
Galactic in SpaceX I'm forgetting one
right now Blue Origin with Jeff Bezos
and they all want to get people up there
to have this experience and we've either
go along for the ride or help share
their story and I think getting that out
there more and more is just a good thing
it's more awe-inspiring and it's more
powerful so I gather you spoke here in
town at planetlab Suzanne yes few days
ago yeah see how their version of space
imagery is gonna play out are you part
of that yeah we would love to be we're
talking with them right now they have
this incredible capacity because of the
number of satellites that they have to
image the entire planet every single day
and get full coverage everywhere on the
earth each each new day they can do that
they also have new higher resolution
satellites that are wondering about that
they're bringing online right now the
reason we haven't worked with them as
much in the past as we've been trying to
get the most high resolution high
detailed imagery we can possibly find to
get people's attention
great to compromise there is that
digital globe only has five satellites
when it has hundreds now I believe so
you need to kind of find a balance to
get the detail but also want to have
enough satellites that you can capture
the image that you want well these
things are so powerful where you're
running the before and after line across
there and one can imagine children
across there running it back across back
across back across in with the daily
planet labs images even though they're
lower resolution in a sense they're
higher resolution in time definitely
yeah I wonder if that's something you
can conjure with yeah absolutely
I think as those images in the
juxtaposed showed when we do that well
it's perhaps more powerful than just a
single image so we want to do that more
and more often and having more and more
satellites up there certainly helps us
to do it is it easy enough to geo
rectify images so that they are perfect
overlay of these kind of
before-and-after things it's possible
and we've also thought about combining
say a drone image and zooming out and
doing it merge into satellite on back
down and yeah we can just go all day
right you mentioned powers of chin as is
but the book and the movie of what your
thought that you could do of this kind
of stuff of the powers of chin approach
yeah what everyone was not able to see
in those images is the ability in which
you're able to zoom in so the example I
showed of the iron ore mine in Australia
one of my favorite things to do is to
zoom into one of the loader trucks
that's working in that mine and you say
this is 40 feet long keep watching it
and you zoom out you zoom out and you
zoom out using out till you can't even
see it anymore mm-hmm
and having that resolution having that
detail makes it possible to get that
sense of scale and we want to do that in
this children's book that were working
on now have you tried any of this stuff
on kids
sounds like I would need to yeah my
sister is a middle school principal and
she will receive the first draft and and
conduct focus groups on a regular weekly
basis and I thought and we talked about
this beforehand it's so much of imagery
for kids is kind of rough cartoony vague
and big splashes of color a big print
and all those kind of stuff it's like
they can't see very well yeah I I assume
they can see a lot better than I think
so I miss it so you know do we know how
much high resolution interesting imagery
will play out for kids has that been
really look into that's what I guess one
needs to test in our focus groups that
you and I are gonna run with the
students what is so interesting to me
and where this idea came from is on the
book tour for the adult version of the
book parents kept coming up to me and
they said we love your book but our kids
love it a lot more and they asked us
yeah they asked us to read it to them
every night before they go to bed and I
was like I was not writing a bedtime
story with mining waste and
deforestation but there's something
about the images that they they love
perhaps it's the abstract nature of them
that they need to find out more it's so
fascinating when you show the book to
kids they don't have this kind of
civilized adult filter that we all have
when like that's a very nice image kids
are like wow that's so cool they just
totally let it all out so I'm excited to
see where that project will go well I'm
getting a sense that part of what's
going on there is is your your short
explanation of what you're seeing in the
image yeah the kid is asking questions
well that's weird
that's great that's wonderful what's
that yeah and then but you've got this
short sort of kids level kid length yeah
attention span that's what it is for
sure yeah yeah I think all of our
attention spans are going down a little
bit so the captions were designed to to
make it something that you never felt
overwhelmed to read you can always get
through three or four sentences tell me
more about rationally
why is resolution so intriguing and
satisfying and it's you know it's the
thing that's been coming in photography
for a while but the the power especially
here where what is being resolved down
at the the pixel level is actually of
interest because that's you know seeing
what color of car that is what brand of
a car that is who's getting into the car
you know you're getting detail that is
actually interesting in the context of
all these other pixels all these other
details at the same time is that what
this is about is that were the Oz coming
from a kind of overwhelm level Wow look
at all that data yeah I think underlying
kind of all of these stories is just
this kind of I don't know if you want to
call it lucky but side effect that this
technology is being developed for other
reasons probably surveillance and the
government is a major customer of
digital globes and they're using these
satellites for other purposes just like
we were going to the moon because of
this space race or the Cold War and we
had this profound awakening in
perspective realization because of it
kind of as an offshoot of it so
hopefully I'm using this technology that
was certainly not made for art and
certainly wasn't created for profound
awakening and perspective for that
reason but I think we need kind of
artists and thinkers and storytellers to
look at technology in that way and find
these things that we can repurpose for
the greater good for the collective to
tell the stories that are needed as a
artist and photographer what I see is a
lot of rectilinear tea yeah so we've got
the rectangular frame yeah and then
often very rectangular human artifacts
which you've light them up yeah
and that sort of adds to their power but
it makes me wonder about other formats
mm-hmm the circular images oval images
several people Steve asks about virtual
reality Andy Lee s when will we see a
360 degree live video of Earth and stuff
do you think outside the box yeah we we
we just had our first I guess you would
call it installation or pop-up event in
San Francisco last week where we're
working with this other company called
near map who has the ability to
photograph a city from an airplane from
multiple angles at the same time and
then they can put that information back
together and create 3d models that you
can then kind of fly through and examine
the city and augmented reality um when
we showed that people were pretty
awestruck and that was a good test and
we definitely want to do more of that in
the future so we are definitely
definitely definitely open to exploring
new mediums new forms of technology that
come out as long as they inspire awe and
people enjoy them so the installation
approach how does that wind up being
different for you than Instagram daily
thing yeah I think really with anything
the real world is better than the world
through a screen and being able to print
these images large so that you can see
details you would never discover on a
small phone screen mm-hm
being able to look at them from
different angles if it's augmented
reality and three-dimensional being able
to move and interact with the imagery is
so powerful are you doing
three-dimensional stuff this is
augmented reality oh I plan all the
special it's the lines are blurry as to
what it is but yeah the more and more we
can get people to be in front of these
images as if you were in an art museum
to make the experience as immersive as
possible to make the images as large as
possible which i think makes them more
immersive is what we want to do to
inspire the overview of it so you've got
you do the stuff of an Instagram and
here comes the comment stream what are
what are some of the comments or
questions that have come up there that
got to you in one way or another you
have the way come out a little more
comments here folks is one of my
favorite things to see over and over is
when I post an image of a city or a
place and someone who lives there
comments and says oh my god I live here
and I could have never imagined it
looked like this hmm and for me that's
like check we did it right they are
operating and moving and thinking small
and this thing popped on their phone
popped up on their phone that day and
they have a new profound understanding
of where they are that happens I guess
more and more than I can ever imagine
but yeah I love when that happens I've
seen something similar when I was
hanging out in Indian reservations I
knew this fairly young guy Navajo Indian
who was serving on the Tribal Council
and I asked him how did you come to do
that he said well you know I've lived
here a number of years and a friend of a
friend had an airplane and he took me up
and I flew over the reservation yeah and
that year I ran for City for the Tribal
Council yeah
or if you affect gets people I think
engaged in sort of responsibility for
that scalers yeah like that he was
outside of his family it was outside of
the immediate neighborhood yeah I mean
my opinion now after doing this for five
years as you obviously don't need to go
to outer space to experience this again
I don't think the images that I'm
creating necessarily equate to an
experience of being in low Earth orbit
and seeing the entire planet I think
it's something different but it is
possible to have that on spiring moment
that recognization of your smallness
from any experience you could get it
from going to the Grand Canyon you could
get it from going to Muir Woods it can
happen anywhere and it doesn't
necessarily matter how you got it but if
we can get more and more of it I think
it would be a much better world in a
much better future here's a kind of a
technical question when I was an army
officer we were taught
- how to analyze aerial photographs yeah
and one of the interesting rules was
maybe run into the shadows stab stomachs
you ever heard that no okay to do is
it's a great name for something anyway
but the view is if you're looking at a
aerial photograph the temptation is to
put north to the top but in the northern
hemisphere a Sun may well be coming from
the other that from under here mmm and
when shadows go away from you everything
turns inside out so canyon walls become
ridge walls mountains become cavities
craters become mountains yeah you've got
it turning around so the shadows come
toward you shadows stab stomachs and
then it all makes a sort of ethereal
sense absolutely have you run into
illusions like definitely and we're
trying to make the images look kind of
as realistic as possible so you would
want to align it and it reminds me of a
comment that we often see kind of more
and more regularly now people say I love
the image but it's upside down and
they're saying it's not north oriented
and I get I reply to every single one of
those and say if you really think about
it there is no upside down
exactly and yet you showed the so called
Earthrise yeah actually it was you know
it was coming around the whim of the
moon yeah and the the orientation that
Andrews photographed was they're looking
at something that's coming around yeah
coming around the corner of the moment
instead of coming up from the horizon
yeah because of this convention right
people what they want right well I mean
the north orientation is an interesting
one but it is in space there really is
North is just one of the great many
directions and you're gonna be tumbling
and doing all these various things when
one of the when a part of largest
holders catalogs could the next Whole
Earth Catalog I needed a kind of a good
white area buying the title the next
oldest catalog and rainbow colors and
that was Antarctica so usually at the
bottom and that's true it was on the top
and people like rusty Schweickart
immediately said no but that is a
convention that has something to do with
wayfinding and with navigation but in
terms of imagery it's basically
meaningless so you can have the
orientation the orientation should be
whatever works for the imagery and the
clarity of understanding what's there
absolutely or that just the sheer impact
of it so do you start with north is up
or do you just not give a damn I think
because I've always approached it from
this artistic angle hmm I usually start
just by spinning it and just keep
spinning it until it feels right
mm-hm and then I make precise
refinements to get as you said the lines
lined up or whatever is best there's
also a lot of thought that goes into how
you crop it what you decide there you go
yeah again the photography I was doing
was just on my own but I think through
that process I learned the most
important part of a photograph is not in
the middle
but it's the edges right you can control
the edges um you can determine where
people will look first and what they're
gonna look at so it's more important to
crop out the unnecessary stuff and to
show the important story and you have a
standard aspect ratio sixteen by nine or
something like that or do you have the
aspect ratio what's image once it's
interesting you say that a few years ago
Instagram made it possible to show
images as large as a phone so for the
book the images are custom cropped for
the exact page they're on to get as much
space as possible but when you're
looking at your phone you're looking at
a vertically oriented rectangle so we
want to mimic that space to take up as
much of the screen as possible to give
you as much of the image as possible so
we're kind of reacting to the format
where we're presenting the images Lou
Cusack asks any thoughts about producing
the film you were inspired by that
overview film definitely one thing I
often say is what's missing from our
stories is the perspective on the ground
and I often think how powerful it would
be to accompany our images with the
perspective on the ground say someone
who works in one of those mines are one
of those shipbreaking facilities or the
people who are living on the left side
of that deforestation image I think
would be especially powerful if they're
at the same time yes there's lots of
amazing Sebastian Salgado and others
have made amazing imagery of the ship
breaking in Pakistan from the surfers
yeah but they're in black and white and
they're you know some other year or even
decade from the images that my guessing
it would be strong as if there's a sort
of sense of simultaneity this is what's
going on on the ground and at the same
time this is what it looks yak from our
images were used recently in the one
strange Rock episode series
what's that Nat Geo right now it's done
Aronofsky creation that's it I think we
would want to do it ourselves and every
but it's nice to see that they can be
used in that format
how will imagery photograph by the James
Webb telescope
us more about the long view of the
beginning of the universe as we know it
influence the whole will that affect
things just any of the looking out
imagery um
come back to the looking in imagery do
you think yeah I would love to kind of
explore that at some point in the future
I've thought daily outlook might be a
good name for that huh
please don't take that domain cuz I
haven't locked it down please but uh
yeah of course I mean that's when people
really start to think about deep time
and the creation of the universe mm-hmm
I think it's more accessible right now
what we're doing and some of that
imagery is viewed as kind of like space
stuff and it's not for everyone
obviously I do not agree with that as
the founder of space club at my old firm
but I think it is incredibly powerful
and something that we would love to tap
into in the future that telescope has
huge potential if they can get it
launched I know it's a little behind
schedule right now in a bit over budget
but fingers crossed that get it up and
going and start capturing these
incredible scenes we've had several
astronomer types and others talk about
basically Carl Sagan's point at the
beginning that this is the only place in
the universe yeah which is very large
that we know of they has life and you've
been as he has part of the off factors
or studying life on Earth from this kind
of perspective must raise the question
for you is there life elsewhere yeah
dope or do you fall on that I'm gonna go
with yes there is life elsewhere
I just think once you start to read and
understand how big the universe is you'd
be a bit selfish or self-centered to
think that just in this tiny tiny tiny
tiny tiny tiny corner of the planet of
the vastness of the cosmos I should say
the planet is there is the only place
I'm not sure we'll ever find other life
but my belief is that there is life
elsewhere what do you think this sense
he's gonna bring something I think about
a lot in terms of climbing all kinds of
stuff what do you think this century is
going to bring in terms of well the
overview effect what else is coming
yeah I've mentioned a few of the things
already I think space tourism as it's
known will make space travel in this new
space race more of a thing mm-hmm
I think those efforts are fundamentally
being led by the SpaceX they are making
reusable rockets which is a game changer
until now launches have been conducted
by launching and then just crashing the
the Rockets into the ocean it's now more
affordable when you land them that means
there will be more satellites in outer
space that means it's more it's gonna be
more likely that we'll be able to send
people to outer space potentially to
Mars which I know Elon Musk wants to do
mm-hmm it also means that there are more
and more satellites going up all the
time there have been some incredible
geostationary satellites launched I
showed the image from discover that was
in 2015 if you go on the NASA website
you can get an image every twenty
minutes of the earth from that satellite
Himawari eight is a Japanese weather
satellite that takes a picture of the
planet every 12 minutes hmm
there is new profound that's huge
stationary as well
yeah well geostationary means that it's
focused on one particular place on the
planet and set the distance again I'm an
astrophysicist at a distance where it
can stay there and it's kind of in
between the Earth and the Sun and it's
focused on one place at one time so
there will be more and more of that I
hope there is new understanding that
comes from it not only about the weather
but about the climate and hopefully kind
of just as I was trying to do was
basically but gets people interested in
space again I wasn't around for the
1960s but from what I understand and
what I've read it was the thing
astronauts were heroes and going to new
places was the future and I think that
can come back and if that comes back
things will be good so our patron Jeff
Bezos is very interested in
getting space colonies going yeah which
is interesting because this goes back to
jury O'Neill's the physicist Gerard
O'Neill's thought that is the surface of
a planet really the best place for an
advanced industrial civilization yeah
but from the overview effect it's
interesting because you know it would be
one of the l1 l2 l3 l4 l5 places that
the is a likely place to have early
space colonies yeah which will have this
perspective on earth they will be seeing
the Earth and Moon and Sun doing their
dance and they will be part of the dance
yeah
and presumably a lot of it will be
turned into weird because you're
protecting against cosmic rays and all
sorts of stuff let and enough Sun that
the Sun actually works but presumably
they'll also be a whole viewing aspect
to it yeah do you have any feeling about
that how about space class I know Jeff
Bezos is definitely a huge proponent of
the viewing aspect Blue Origin is
advertising that they have the largest
windows in space right now and they have
the measurements listed in their ticket
brochures to go one-on-one of their
flights so the overview effect and
viewing the earth is definitely a major
component of that experience for them I
hope it's part of it inevitably when
people go to these space stations
they're gonna be looking out the window
a lot of the astronauts who have spent
time on the International Space Station
complain that they don't have enough
time for earth gazing as they call it
they've got to do all these other things
and experiments and they just want to
look out the window most of the time so
an interesting thing happened with the
space station there was there was kind
of a pity and contempt that was growing
for the space station after been up
there a few years and they've done a few
energy experiments and people are saying
what you know what's this all about yeah
and then they put in that bay window
yeah and started doing you know videos
of the awesome but here the
strolling by and all this kind of stuff
once they put that big window in the the
the sign bit on the space station it
flipped from minus to plus and so
everybody's interested in it and the
astronauts are carrying on they want to
hang out by the window yeah do you think
that's just just that it's just the
visual I hope so I even more than that
the astronauts have had an opportunity
to do spacewalks say it is the most
incredible thing when you don't have the
windows in front of you I guess it's
similar to you're not looking not
enjoying the windows seen on an airplane
because the windows too small once they
get out there and they can see
everything they're like this is it this
is what it's all about Mike Massimino
writes about that in his new book saying
it was the most profound incredible
thing he's ever experienced well it's
good argument for the person who is
suggesting a virtual reality version of
all this I think that's coming yeah so
last question what's what's coming for
you what do you plan to do and what do
you really really want to do yeah I
think we've covered a lot of it again
working on the children's book right now
you mentioned the film but underlying
everything that I'm doing now everything
that I intend to do in the future I'm
probably gonna stop before I do anything
and ask myself the question will this
inspire the overview effect will this
inspire awe and am i doing something
that presents people with an opportunity
to learn and enjoy and appreciate the
planet and if I can do that I think the
project will be a success I mean pretty
well so far thank you for coming here
[Applause]
[Music]